even though Pixar studios has been
pumping out thoroughly quality content
for a couple decades now it's no secret
the studio likes to sneak in a
tear-jerking moment or two whenever they
can this isn't a bad thing at all and
the maturity and brevity with which
difficult life topics are discussed and
Pixar films has been largely regarded as
one of the studio's biggest strengths
with their latest film onward tragedy is
in no short supply however that's not to
say the film is nothing more than an
introspective reflection on loss in the
nuclear family on the contrary the
film's expert balance of joy and pain
makes it an impactful yet entertaining
viewing for any movie goer regardless of
a chore experience where any of these
heavy-hitting picks our classics based
on real-life events today we're diving
into the wild world of Pixar to find out
and let us be the first to say the
answers may surprise you kicking off our
list is the most recent Pixar film
onward don't worry because this film
recently hit the box office we won't
reveal any spoilers however if you've
only even seen the trailer for this film
it's pretty easy to gauge the potential
emotional heaviness of this brothers go
on a quest to find dad movie the
director of onward dan scanlon had a
childhood similar to that of the
brothers in the film yen and barley
Lightfoot played by Tom Holland and
Chris Pratt the film follows the two
brothers as they try to bring their
father back to life so they can meet him
even if it's just for one day dan
scanlon had a similar upbringing his
father died in 1977 when he was just one
year old
neither dan scanlon nor his brother
remember their father when they were
growing up apparently the two brothers
tried to recreate their father or at
least make some sense of who he was
through old photographs and home movies
dan scanlon the director of monsters
University drew from his personal
childhood experience to create the idea
for onward Scanlan said in a recent
interview with Vanity Fair when I was
trying to come up with an idea for the
film you look at sad things you look
towards your fears because that's where
drama comes from you look for the fun -
when I was talking to my mom on the
phone and I said the truth is I don't
know what to make a movie about because
nothing sad ever happened to me you lost
your father his mother replied and I
said yeah but that's not sad because I
don't remember him and that's why it's
sad his mother said alright though it's
hard to say a movie that takes place in
the future can be based on real-life
events from the past we're going out on
a limb here to say that this film is a
caution
retail of tragic events yet to come how
did you feel after the first time you
saw Wally did you leave the theater
misty-eyed and a little confused that a
couple robots could yield such a
powerful emotional response we got to
give credit to the director and
co-writer Andrew Stanton for producing
such an emotionally profound piece of
cinema it could be argued that wall-e is
based on tragic real-life events that
are likely to happen in the future
planet Earth becoming so covered in
garbage by human overconsumption that
many people start living on low-hanging
spaceships to resume life as normal or
as normal as it can be given the post
trash apocalypse circumstances and hey
remember the TV screens everyone in
wall-e sat in front of looks a little
like a smartphone no doubt aside from
being a warning of what's to come while
he also used nostalgic themes of the
past to inform the film's vision of the
future the American Film Institute named
it one of the best films of 2008 in a
review that also praised the film saying
Stanton and his team have created a
classic screen character from a metal
trash compactor who rides to the rescue
of a planet buried in the debris that
embodies the broken promise of American
life not since Charlie Chaplin's little
[ __ ] has so much story so much emotion
been conveyed without words how did you
feel the first time you saw Wally let us
know in the comments
perhaps regarded as one of the most
heart-wrenching Pixar films today up is
anything but up as it deals with some
very real human experiences like growing
older cancer industrialization and
inevitable change in Seattle Washington
a similar situation to the plot of up
took place this is a photograph of Edith
Masefield in Oregon native born in 1921
she was the owner of a one hundred and
eight year old farmhouse in the
neighborhood of Ballard in Seattle over
recent years the neighborhood of Ballard
has over gone intense changes due to
industrialization though she traveled a
lot in her early life she always kept
the farmhouse and returned to it to live
in America when her mother became ill
later in life
despite the rapidly changing
neighborhood of Ballard Edith and her
mother wanted to keep the farmhouse in
fact Edith wanted to pass away in the
house just like her mother did in 2006
Edith was offered 1 million dollars for
the property her house resided on she
turned down the offer when the
high-rises began to build around her the
construction noise didn't bother her at
all she went on the record saying I went
through
or to the noise doesn't bother me
they'll get it done someday though Edith
passed away in 2008 a construction chief
around the architectural projects of
Edith's house named Barry Martin wrote a
book about his experience with Edith
this film isn't based on someone's
particular true life experience so much
as it is millions of people's
experiences the 2015 film received mass
appraisal upon its release and has since
been regarded as one of the best Pixar
films to date but did you know the
original scenes from the film had to be
altered because some of it was even too
sad for Pixar in an interview with Yahoo
Richard kind who played Bing bong in the
film gave some insight into a tragic
deleted scene from inside out who
remembers the scene and inside out when
Bing bong sacrifices himself into the
memory dump to save joy kind said some
interesting things about the original
cut of that scene the version that came
out to the public was about 20 to 40
seconds shorter than the scene we
recorded because it got a little too
hard hitting I asked the director do I
have to get laughs with this and they
said no this is a sober moment and I
told joy don't you understand
we are forgotten we don't count anymore
think of the added emotional impact the
addition of those last two lines would
have added to the scene we also can't
help but remember that scene from Toy
Story 3 where Andy learns the hard
lesson that giving up his toys was
inevitable and necessary as he grew
older and became more mature still we
think these scenes are heartbreaking and
it just goes to show how talented the
creators at Pixar really are finding
Nemo is rife with harrowing anecdotes of
oceanic pollution and the consequences
climate change has on marine wildlife
many news articles have come out since
the film hit theaters in 2003 with
catchy yet for learned headlines like
losing Nemo clownfish cannot adapt to
climate change and so forth which is
true and while the film itself is
light-hearted for the most part the
well-being of marine biology is no
laughing matter
take for instance the previously
mentioned losing Nemo article written by
the Bangkok Post in 2019 we are in fact
losing Nemo due to the loss of healthy
coral reefs worldwide mainly found in
Papua New Guinea clownfish make their
lives among sea anemone while
temperatures in the oceans rise coral
and anemones often can't survive leaving
clownfish without a home and though it
may not have been the film's intention
to shed light on this unfortunate
nautical phenomenon it has certainly
raised awareness for the survival of
clownfish bringing entertainment and
education into the same important
conversation while dun Pixar Pete docter
the director of Monsters Inc didn't have
any particular devastating personal
anecdotes from which the source material
came for monsters Inc
however the film could have been viewed
as a meditation on corporate life and
the trials and tribulations of working
in a heavily pure AA critized
environment what sort of effects does
this have on someone working in a place
like the monsters do in the film
throughout several interviews Pete
docter maintains his optimistic demeanor
going on the record to say he is in high
spirits and as a religious person though
he has never set out to make a religious
film he was also heavily influenced by
Hayao Miyazaki saying he loved the
beautiful details and Miyazaki's work
can you notice any similarities between
Monsters Inc and say spirited away
artists are constantly being influenced
by other artists and using the world
around them as inspiration for their own
work let us know in the comments if
you're particularly inspired by any
artists perhaps regarded as the oldest
tragedy in existence on earth the
asteroid that wiped out the dinosaurs
was certainly a devastating natural
disaster that is still widely talked
about to this day in a rare case of
events Pixar decided to make this
historical event less sad by placing the
good dinosaur in a timeline where the
asteroid that hit earth 65 million years
ago actually passed safely through
Earth's atmosphere and didn't hit any
living dinosaurs what happens next in
the good dinosaur well you'll have to
see it for yourself but we can assure
you it's packed with some classic Pixar
magic and will make you think and feel
indefinitely well worth the watch in our
opinion especially if you like dinosaurs
well not necessarily heartbreaking the
creators of Toy Story did base their
characters on real toys from the bygone
era
for instance woody is heavily influenced
by the famous puppet Howdy Doody a
popular puppet from the 1950s he even
had his own television show
Bo Peep Woody's love interest was based
on the Nursery Rhyme character of the
same name
Pixar actually wanted to use Barbie as
the original Bo Peep but Mattel refused
to give Disney the license to the
character
Barbie because Pixar wasn't really that
famous when Toy Story was made how do
you think Toy Story would have been
different if Barbie had been in the
films instead of Bo Peep The Incredibles
is arguably one of the most lighthearted
Pixar films ever made though it
obviously isn't based on any true life
events unless there are people walking
among us with real superpowers it is
still full of emotionally charged scenes
and characters every viewer can relate
to
creator Brad Bird actually said in an
interview that he wrote the story for
The Incredibles in 1993 during a
particularly tumultuous time in his
personal life and career he was working
on the Iron Giant at the time and was
subsequently incredibly busy he didn't
get nearly as much time with his family
as he would have liked and was sometimes
unhappy because of his workload Brad
Bird was quoted in an interview saying
consciously this was just a funny movie
about superheroes but I think that what
was going on in my life definitely
filtered into the movie as the story of
The Incredibles developed bird based his
characters superpowers on their
archetypes in the family unit one more
piece of Miyazaki trivia we really love
goes as follows
apparently when hiyo himself visited
Pixar and saw story reels for The
Incredibles Bird asked him if they made
any sense or if they were just American
nonsense Miyazaki said I think it's a
very adventurous thing you were trying
to do in an American film we love how
Pixar isn't afraid to get emotional in a
light-hearted kid's film are you excited
to see on word in theaters what are some
of your favorite Pixar moments we missed
let us know all your thoughts in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to the things to keep up to
date with all our latest videos